hey I'm Scott Butterworth here at e3
2016 with Miguel concepción we're here
to talk to you about some of the racing
games here on display primarily Forza
horizon 3 and Gran Turismo sport how did
the two biggest racing games here at the
show Miguel endure you had a chance to
play horizon just a couple days ago
right mm-hmm I had played Forza horizon
3 over to showcase at that xbox was was
hosting and it was this four part demo
that involved just getting a feel for
all the vehicles all the different
landscapes because of the Australian
setting the setting itself was a nice
change over the European Riviera that I
loved and Forza horizon 2 by the same
time I do understand why playground
games would want to a nice change of
scenery for the sequel yeah it
definitely opens up a lot of new
opportunities primarily for off-road
racing if I click demo we saw I started
out in a Lamborghini once I kind of
drive through some jungle but then at
one point there's like trophy trucks
wings onto the road and suddenly I was
controlling that and kind of driving on
a dirt path and then did the demo ended
I was driving like a dune buggy kind of
thing right as crazy course chasing a
helicopter carrying a cheap so close the
horizon still has kind of that like very
fun approach to racing it's kind of like
a celebratory atmosphere like music
pulsing the whole time it's definitely
kind of more like the fun party version
of Forza more than you know like like
the previous right yeah absolutely I
mean the one thing the two takeaways I
had about the demo was playing four by
fours it's not something you really
associate with fordzilla Rison so it's
going to be it's going to prove to be a
really great challenge for both the
players and for playground games to
actually make it challenging but also
fair and the absurdity of you know
chasing this hella transport that's
dropping this Jeep like 50 yards for the
finish line you know it does speak to
the just the absurdity of like Forza
horizon especially when you think about
those plane chases enforce ERISA - yeah
so it's not always super serious but it
is a really pretty game and it did seem
to control pretty well Gran Turismo on
the other hand I've seen a chance play
that that is a very serious game that is
absolutely the more I see the game the
more it's clear that like the franchise
in general it's really for people who
like follow car blogs or could name
every single driver in f1 like
for motor sports fans it is like still
just painstakingly realistic so much
attention to details it's just every car
is painstakingly modeled and everything
about the game is very much committed at
authenticity so it does really feel like
an official mainline Gran Turismo game
even if it's not a numbered release yeah
you know actually got a chance to talk
to a cousin or a Yamaguchi who is sort
of like the longtime leader of the
franchise and he was telling me that in
his mind there is enough game there that
it could have been Gran Turismo seven
they just decided to name it something a
little different because they think of
it as almost kind of like a fresh start
for the for the franchise it's kind of
breaking new ground because it's focused
more on online competition but in a way
according to him it's also returning to
the serious roots of wanting to invite
people into Motorsports try to be maybe
just slightly more accessible even if it
is still very much a simulation game
trying to just draw people in and and
let anybody who's interested in racing
you know have a good time and and just
give them a reason to come and play a
motor sports game it does speak to mine
just the I mean speaking about a sec
accessibility that sort of been what the
mantra of sports as a franchise has been
so you know it's nice to know that you
know before Gran Turismo sport is going
to have you know they're gonna have some
make some attempts at making it just
that much more accessible I can ex they
have like a brake assist and a drive is
it seem to help at least a little bit
but according to Yamaguchi they're also
going to have like tutorials and
licensed tracks and stuff like that to
help players kind of get eased into the
experience a little bit which is
definitely good because those games are
pretty demanding I mean you can't just
like hold down the accelerator and
expect to win like you really have to be
careful and pick your passes and you
know know the lines of the tracks and
everything lights it's you know a very
cool I said very committed authenticity
right well I mean it's a nice it's a
nice foil for the openness of Forza
horizon 3 and I mean I definitely see
you know the benefits of both yeah you
know they are sort of the two biggest
games they are extremely different
before is being open world being coop
being kind of this party game Gran
Turismo being very serious and a much
more traditional structure of you know
individual events and more focused on
online competition and maybe even having
some eSports ambitions so it'll be
really interesting to see how these two
actually you know work out when they
would they really believe there
coming out later this year so to stay
tuned to GameXplain we're gonna have way
more on both of these games and more
from e3 2016